evan is in idaho falls idaho hi
evan welcome to the ramsay show uncle
dave how are you
better than i deserve sir how can we
help
i'm i'm here with my wife tyra and uh we
got a question for you
okay we've been on baby step now baby
step two
for some months now um we have
about seven thousand dollars in debt
that we're taking care of
and with a baby on the way yay
unfortunately some taxes we've got about
another five
coming down the line okay for
for more um debt and we
made the decision together that i'm
going to go back to school at the end of
this year
so with debt and a baby and school
we are wondering where to focus our
money while being on step two
big step two
okay i'm um
it's incongruent for we made the
decision to go back to school
together at the end of the year if you
can't pay for it
when you're working to get out of debt
those two things don't work together
unless you can afford to pay for it
after you're out of debt what's your
household income
uh currently just over forty thousand
okay and so you need twelve thousand
dollars to pay off the five thousand
dollars in irs debt
and uh the seven thousand dollars in
debt and you need how much to go back to
school
um with three years of school
i anticipate maybe
no more than 10 a year so let's say 30
000 for school
yeah and who's how who's working you're
working during this time
um we will be so anticipated full-time
school part-time work yes and how are
you paying
10 000 a year in paying for your family
we are anticipating
some grants now i guess you should know
if if those don't go through uh
getting a loan out for school is not an
option for us so
um what kind of agreement what kind of
grants are you anticipating
um the i was under the impression
that there's some grants out there to
help families go to school
and that now i don't know the math but i
was gonna
see if those are available and
then do the math to see what would what
it would cost and how much work would
have to be done
to continue why school why school i'm
just curious what's the reason for going
back to school
um uh the field that i'm interested in
requires a degree
what and the construction management
no it doesn't yeah that's uh that's a
complete and utter myth
uh dave knows a little something about
construction um
lots of people just could do
construction management all day long
without the degree and
yeah you could work your way up the
ladder you know that are you in
construction
i am yeah yeah so you basically said you
think you need a degree somebody's
convinced you or you just have this myth
out there that you need this degree to
lead people
in the construction business you're
already in the construction business so
let's set that aside for right now
what's the payoff date well as of before
you called you guys have been thinking
through this when were you planning to
pay the 12
off um our
calculator tells us um what was the
title
you know to get our debt taken roughly
roughly i think we're looking at
three years three years to pay 12 000
off
well you know what you're right with
this new with the baby bill and the
taxes that probably is increased by
a couple years no dude you missed what i
was getting at
that that's way too much to to pay off
that money
yeah yeah that this needs to be a matter
of months not a matter of years
that's a small amount in the grant and
no you're not going back to school to
your debt free
no and um and no you probably don't need
to go back to school to do this
so all of this to say that helps with
the priorities a lot
um yeah uh uh you know i think you need
to do some more
is a four-year degree in construction
management necessary for you to do
construction management
no it is not a precursor there's not a
licensing issue
there's not a problem with that you you
do have to have the knowledge to do
construction management and it's that a
way to get the knowledge yes it is a way
there are other ways for you to skin
this cat
and i highly recommend you do the other
ways because you have a family to feed
and raise
at this point but dude you need a system
where you are
100 debt free in about
six months and that's going to involve
like two extra jobs
you're raising your household income and
getting on a tight budget if you made
fifteen hundred dollars a month
delivering pizza five nights a week
which you can do as an example uh you
would be debt-free in just a matter of
months
if you threw all of that at the 12 000.
and um
and you gotta get this irs whatever
caused this irs problem it has to stop
and so that means you're under
withholding or something else you did
that you can't do anymore but um
so here's your hint for the future we
don't
need to make decisions that we can't pay
for
so we made the decision i'm going back
to school at the end of the year
but we have no freaking idea how we're
going to do it at this point except
these mythical grants that you have in
your mind that i don't think are out
there i think you're going to have
trouble finding those i hope you can
find them and i don't mind if you go to
school and pay for it but i don't i
think you're
going through a lot of trouble to try to
increase your income and there's other
ways to do that on your career track
yeah
first things first i mean i tell people
this on on the cancom show look
we can pursue the dream once we get
financially stable and oh by the way
when we get financially stable meaning
getting out of debt getting emergency
fund in place
and then having a plan to be able to
cash flow or getting qualified
uh you get there faster than if you try
to do it this way which is go to school
and i gotta say this dave i i
i gotta do a little rant here uh and
it's quick
but folks if education if
higher education isn't the only way to
do what you want to do
or the best way then don't
assume you have to do it so ask the
question do the research
if i want to be in construction
management be successful is a four-year
degree
the only way to do that no is it the
best way
i'm not even sure on that one to be
honest with you i have to do some
research i want to talk to winston your
son-in-law on that one
because i think if you get in the
business and you really figure out from
people that are construction managers
well i wrote the book the proximity
principle
get around some people sean uh
uh who uh are doing this excuse me evan
i apologize evan
get around people that are actually
successful construction managers even if
it's a phone call or a friend of a
friend of a friend and go hey
how would one how could i how could i
get the information i need without going
to get a four-year degree
what just humor me friend what would it
take to get there without a four-year
degree
you'd be surprised four classes at the
vo-tech school
on project management and on
construction technique to add to what
your knowledge you already have working
in the business you're probably there
and oh by the way you probably could
take on another construction job or
something
in this field right now and they would
pay off the 12 grand and if it depends
on the size of the company they might
pay for
you to take the classes to become one of
their managers you bet
yeah there's another that's your angle
it's not
stop your life and hope grants will
carry your little family along
that's a scary scenario you're painting
out there brother i wouldn't do that
i wouldn't wish that on my worst enemy
thanks for calling
this is the ramsey show